hard to think of Entertainment Tonight  without doing  [Music]  if you press this button right here  ready  [Music]  Entertainment Tonight is about me me  Entertainment Tonight Entertainment  Tonight  do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do  do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do  do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do I um I  have my back dude just the entertainment  theme song oh my god entertainment  alright tonight Jenna Jenna it's it's an  antenna no no no no it's just a little  remix in the beginning the movies who  got busted for dope - nah  [Music]  because you know they will use it and  now go to cover show we'll be right back  yeah eighty come party with us it's  Oscar night 1996 duty doubted about it  deep deep deep ready maker no no no no  no no no no no no no see this will take  you right in the commercial  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]